[Musique]
sous bien des aspects le zombie en 1960
est une figure émanant de la
contre-culture le terme et critiquer
nous on peut en faire une définition
simple en définissant la contre-culture
comme l'explosion de mouvements
contestataires venus principalement de
la jeunesse et pour dénoncer la
domination culturelle de la bourgeoisie
ce n'est donc pas anodin que le premier
film de romero soit sorti en 1968
si on replace les choses dans leur
contexte 1968 ce n'est pas uniquement
l'explosion des classes ouvrières et
étudiantes françaises qui ont culminé
dans notre fameux mai 68 c'est un
phénomène de contestation qui se
sédimente à l'échelle mondiale dans le
cas des états unis la contestation
s'organise principalement autour de la
dénonciation de la guerre du vietnam
dont on commence tout juste à percevoir
toute l'horreur ainsi qu'autour de la
question raciale qui gangrènent la
société américaine par exemple le
discours i have a dream de martin luther
king s'est déroulée en 1963 et il a
lui-même été assassiné en avril 1968
donnant ainsi une nouvelle énergie au
mouvement des civils rights qui se
radicalise notamment cette année là la
contre-culture fait émerger de nombreux
mouvements qui ont pour but de faire
bouger les codes d'une société d'après
guerre que l'on juge trop figée en
musique on voit l'apparition du heavy
metal du free jazz ou même du hip hop
qui commencent leur entreprise de
contestation de l'ordre établi
on voit également l'apparition de
nouveaux mouvements sociaux comme le
féminisme ou de nouveaux modes de vie
comme le mouvement hippie qui se
cristallise également en cours des
années 60 et qui vont notamment critiqué
la société de consommation tout juste
naissante à cette époque sur le plan
artistique on se défait peu à peu des
codes bien établis de l'art sacré pour
voir apparaître de nouvelles formes
d'expressions comme les graffitis le
land art et même leur grade artistique
de façon générale avec le mouvement fric
la beat generation et le mouvement punk
et j'en passe pour ce qui est du cinéma
on peut parler de cinéma underground
même si le mot reste encore aujourd'hui
difficile à définir non voit
l'apparition de nouveaux modes
d'expression qui s'inspirent souvent
d'ailleurs de la nouvelle vague
française et qui cherche à se détourner
des cadeaux traditionnels de production
et de diffusion pour offrir une vision
plus personnel du cinéma et de la
société
dans ce contexte la nuit des
morts-vivants s'inscrit complètement
dans cette veine et contre culturel
c'est un film en noir et blanc
complètement fauché menée par un jeune
réalisateur de 27 ans et qui laisse voir
des corps morts revenir à la vie qu'on
pourrait facilement interprétée comme la
culpabilité de la société américaine
obligé de faire face aux morts de la
guerre du vietnam qu'elle essaie tant
bien que mal d'oublier
on peut également noter que l'acteur
principal et noir ce qui n'est pas
habituel dans les films de cette époque
et d'ailleurs c'est toujours pas
vraiment habituel aujourd'hui si on fait
attention quand il est interrogé à ce
sujet au romero a toujours dit avoir
choisi cet acteur simplement parce que
il était le meilleur comédien avoir
passé le casting mais le contexte social
de cette époque ne peut nous empêcher de
penser qu'il ya également derrière ce
soit une part de revendications
politiques
si on fait un peu attention dans tous
les films de romero
on trouve parmi les personnages
principaux un personnage noir et qu'ils
ne meurent pas ce qui est suffisamment
rare dans les films d'horreur pour être
protégé doit enfin si dans la nuit des
morts-vivants le personnage principal
finit bien par mourir à la toute fin du
film de la main de la milice d'hommes
blancs qui devait précisément le
protéger et qui le prennent pour un
zombie
ça en dit long sur le sous texte que
l'on peut en tirer
ça va alléger et les morts aller le
chercher et vous pourrez aussi le [__]
au feu d'un point de vue social et
économique
le zombie est également une critique de
la société capitaliste où les individus
ne sont plus que des corps
indifférenciée qu'on utilise comme une
pure force de travail les zombies n'ont
pas de personnalité ils sont
complètement interchangeables et ils
sont en nombre suffisant pour être
toujours présent
on dirait bien une représentation
directe des classes ouvrières aliéné par
le capitaliste la critique de romero
rejoint également une critique assez
répandu dans les mouvements contre
culturel la critique de la société de
consommation
c'est particulièrement visible dans le
deuxième film parce qu'il se déroule
roulement de tambours dans d'un centre
commercial c'est complètement justifié
scénaristiquement parce que c'est
effectivement un lieu rêvé pour des
personnages qui ont besoin de vivre pour
s'en sortir et ça permet de nous
présenter des scènes saisissantes et
même drôle où l'on compare visuellement
les populations obnubilés par leur désir
de consommation à des zombies
regardez plutôt
[Musique]
il
quant à la justification des zombies
dans ce lieu là aussi le film critique
la mise en place d'une société où la
chose la plus structurante est important
dans la vie d'une personne c'est d'aller
passer ses journées au centre commercial
il centre mais il nous cherchent ils
savent qu'on est ici lors c'est par
habitude sans savoir au juste pourquoi
dans leur vie passée ils venaient ici
s'en souviennent fragments et qui sont
ils ils sont nous c'est tout
une fois posé ses différentes critiques
on peut se demander s'il existe une
solution si on peut se protéger de cette
société mais la réponse de romero semble
plutôt pessimiste cela se voit un des
éléments centraux de tous les films de
zombies la contagion et oui je n'en ai
pas encore parlé mais si vous fait
mordre par un zombie vous devenez vous
même un zombie et ça c'est vrai quelle
que soit leur origine supposée le média
utilisé ou l'histoire racontée c'est une
constante incontournable du genre et ça
soulève pas mal de questions c'est en
fait très rare que l'on connaisse
véritablement l'origine des zombies si
certains films d'hier ont explicitement
qu'il s'agit d'un virus ou d'une
expérimentation qui a mal tourné comme
dans 28 jours plus tard on peut citer le
risque d'un antivol world war z et j'en
passe les films de romero ne tranche
jamais vraiment sur l'origine de cette
épidémie
si les personnages cherchent
effectivement à étudier le phénomène
toutes les hypothèses restent le plus
souvent ouvertes ce qui peut donc
laisser le soin aux spectateurs de
penser qu'il s'agirait d'une espèce
d'évolution naturelle de la société et
qui me conforte personnellement dans
l'idée que le zombie n'est que
l'allégorie des dysfonctions de notre
société moderne la contagion a donc une
importance capitale dans les films de
zombies puisque en plus de placer le
personnage dans une atmosphère de
tension constante
cela permet de symboliser que tout le
monde peut se faire digérer rejetée par
notre société
n'importe qui peut se transformer en
zombies par simple morsure et cela pose
d'ailleurs de nombreuses questions
éthiques parce que à partir du moment où
une personne est mordu il faut
absolument de l'éliminer parce que sa
transformation futur est inévitable peu
importe que ce soit votre père votre
soeur ou l'amour de votre vie
la personne mordue finira toujours par
se transformer en une espèce de grosses
doc bavante et grumeleuses qui tentera
de vous grignotez allègrement l'occiput
sans que vous puissiez faire grand chose
d'autre pour les calmer que de leur
faire péter la cavité oculaire à grands
coups de tisonnier de fait la contagion
est généralisée et même les sphères de
socialisation qui habituellement nous
aide à nous protéger du risque ne sont
d'aucun secours ici c'est
particulièrement frappant dans le
premier film où on assiste à une scène
de dévoration d'une famille attaqué par
ses propres enfants
verdict même votre famille n'est pas un
groupe suffisamment soudés pour vous
garantir une relative sécurité
les individus sont donc isolés renvoyé à
eux mêmes
et les films mettent souvent en avant
des groupes de survivants venant de
milieux socio culturel très disparate
pour insister sur l'explosion de toutes
les formes de solidarité préexistantes
ce que le zombie représente c'est donc
la perte de l'humanité tant d'un point
de vue social que psychologique à la
fois par les pertes des liens sociaux
pour le versant social mais également
par la perte de sa propre réflexivité
déjà propre humanité pour le versant
psychologique
d'ailleurs ce qui est notable c'est que
la perte de son humanité semble être le
plus grand mal que puisse imaginer les
personnages en mal plus grand que la
mort elle même parce que beaucoup
préfèrent se donner la mort plutôt que
de savoir quels seront transformés en
zombies
même s'ils ne savent finalement parce
que ça fait réellement que de se
transformer en zombie on a même le droit
à une petite médaille religieuse au
passage mais ça on va y revenir et on
n'y rien parce que romero fait passer
pas mal d'idées et de messages au
travers de ses films et s'il est choisi
d'utiliser les zombies comme vecteur de
sens c'est bien de l'humanité en général
qu'il parle et il n'hésite pas se
montrer assez critique envers l'humanité
[Musique]
en fait de façon générale il tente de
dresser un portrait de tout ce qui ne va
pas dans la société américaine moderne
de tout ce qui constitua un excès ou qui
seraient devenus pathologique atteint on
a déjà parlé de la guerre de la question
raciale de l'hygiénisme à outrance mais
dans ce film romero va se voir vraiment
revenir sur ce qui constitue pour lui la
lie de toute l'humanité
c'est à dire l'armée et les questions
religieuses de façon générale l'armée et
la religion sont effectivement deux
instance garante de l'ordre social au
sein de la société et elles sont bien
mises à mal par l'apocalypse zombie
romero montre à quel point ces deux
institutions sont dépassés par la
situation dans un dialogue entre deux
policiers qui sont ici pour représenter
les forces armées et un prêtre estropiés
dont j'analyse l'infirmité comme
l'incapacité de l'institution religieuse
à donner un sens à la situation
on assiste effectivement un aveu de
faiblesse de la part du prêtre mais
celui ci mais néanmoins nos personnages
en garde en soulignant que la force
n'est peut-être pas non plus la solution
est plus fort que nous mais bientôt je
crois que les plus forts ce sont
les morts se remettent à marcher
messieurs je vous abstenir de tuer les
vaincus d'avancé
par la suite la religion sera souvent
utilisée comme un moyen de justifier
l'apocalypse zombie avec notamment
l'expression qui reviendra presque dans
chaque film comme un leitmotiv
quand l'enfer n'a plus assez de place
les morts reviennent sur la terre on
retrouve la même idée dans le troisième
film nous subissons la punition du
créateur il a voulu nous faire payer nos
fautes et on peut noter dans les deux
cas ces phrases sont prononcés par les
personnages qui nous sont le plus
sympathique par son d'une vision assez
neutre de la religion romero pousse donc
peu à peu son propos plus loin en
faisant une critique du fanatisme
religieux
de la même façon que la signification
religieuse est appuyé dans cette scène
de façon grotesque
il montre que dans des situations
extrêmes les hommes sont prêts à tout
pour trouver un but une raison une
explication à ce qui leur arrive et se
conforte alors dans l'idée que cela
arrive bel et bien pour une raison et
qu'ils sont en train d'expliquer une
faute
cela est rendu extrêmement visible dans
le remake du crépuscule les
morts-vivants réalisé en 2004 par zack
snyder
oui oui zack snyder je parle bien du mec
qui nous a fait baver sur les abdos
rutilants des spartiates et ceux non
moins rutilant de ben affleck dans
batman superman et bien avant de devenir
monsieur dc comics il a fait ses
premières armes dans le gore en
proposant une nouvelle version du
deuxième film de romero
si les aficionados de la première heure
ont gueulé parce que c'est toujours bien
de gueuler pour prouver que nous au
moins on est fans de l'original
je trouve cette version intéressante
notamment parce qu'elle pousse le
curseur un cran plus loin pour ce qui
est de la critique du fanatisme
religieux et de là à dire que ça le
place
indubitablement comme un film post 11
septembre il n'y a qu'un pas que je ne
franchirais pas parce que je m'en
voudrais de verser ici dans la platitude
consensuelles alors qu'on a plein de
choses plus intéressantes que ça à dire
la prétérition mais pour ce qui est du
discours sur la religion je vous invite
à regarder cet extrait riehl sachez que
l'enfer déborde
et que satan satan envoie ses morts chez
nous pourquoi parce que vous pratiquez
le sexe en dehors du mariage vous
pratiquer l'avortement
vous avez des relations homosexuelles
des mariages homosexuels
mais paie des préservatifs
mes amis nous savons
[Musique]
que lorsqu'il y aura plus de place en
enfer
[Musique]
les morts
reviendront sur la terre
voilà donc une bonne réutilisation de la
phrase précédemment évoqués à mon sens
et on sent bien à travers ce simple
extrait les dérives qui peuvent survenir
d'une société en quête de sens puisque
c'est bien de ça qu'il s'agit on cherche
dans la religion les réponses que l'on
n'a pas sous la main parce que l'on
n'est pas prêt à affronter les dures
réalités du monde réel
après les zombies c'est juste un moyen
de pousser au maximum le curseur de
dures réalités et comme le disait le
médecin de desproges en énumérant les
façons de mieux supporter la vie et dr
vous n'avez pas d'autres médication elle
suggéré bon qui est bien la religion
c'est une défense naturelle qui permet à
ceux qui la possèdent de supporter
relativement bien la vie en se
persuadant qu'elle a un sens et qu'ils
sont immortels
écoutez docteur soit aussi remis un prix
mais qu'est-ce qu'on serait pas prêt à
croire pour donner un sens au monde donc
d'une certaine manière on pourrait dire
que c'est simplement ça que les envies
représente le vide la contingence
l'absence de sens et que finalement ils
sont peut-être neutre moralement mais
que c'est l'humanité elle même qui va se
pervertir en tentant de leur donner un
sens et justement la guerre on y vient
parce que romero ne fait pas une
critique en règle de la religion il ya
d'ailleurs dans ses films des
personnages attachants qui croient en
justification religieuse
il nous met juste en garde contre les
apories qui peuvent survenir si on fait
de la religion la seule institution
pouvant expliquer le monde mais il
critique également la mise en place d'un
système qui serait basée sur l'armée et
la hiérarchie parce que contrairement à
la religion qui sur moralise les
individus l'armée a plutôt tendance à la
démoraliser le enfin le mot est mal
choisi ses pas démoraliser dans le sens
des prix mais c'est plutôt à moraliser
dans le sens privé de morale voire nier
l'existence même d'une morale pour se
baser uniquement sur la hiérarchie on
pourrait faire le lien avec la théorie
de la banalité du mal d'hannah arendt
mais j'ai déjà prévu d'en parler plus
tard et il faudrait que j'en rajoute au
moins 42 minutes à cet épisode donc on
va enchaîner
romero va véritablement développer cet
aspect dans le troisième film de la saga
le jour des morts-vivants
alors que le premier nous présentait une
lutte contre l'envahisseur inconnu par
des personnages retranchés dans une
maison
le deuxième film raconte et la
difficulté de faire passer le message
d'alerté à une société obnubilée par la
consommation
le troisième film se déroule dans un
bunker militaire et pousse à l'extrême
la thématique de l'enfermement
le tout premier plan du film est
d'ailleurs révélateur un personnage
prostré dans une salle aux murs
blanc est venu ce qui fait écho à la
claustrophobie des films précédents en
insistant sur l'abandon social du
personnage qui est lui-même
hanté par des souvenirs traumatiques
oups pardon pour la crise cardiaque par
rapport aux films précédents
l'apocalypse zombie est encore pousser
d'un cran puisque on découvre une ville
complètement abandonné aux morts les
dollar s'envole dans le vent comme des
feuilles mortes se ramassent à la pelle
dans les folles prairies de
l'insouciance pardon je m'emporte sa
bien aimée bien évidemment souligné le
fait que ce qui avait de la valeur dans
l'ancien monde n'a évidemment plus court
ici il en va peut-être de même pour
l'art comme pourrait le suggérer ce
zombie qui pose négligemment sa main sur
la bobine des places du théâtre edison
et puis watts
il ya un crocodile ya un fucking
crocodile au beau milieu de la ville
c'est fou qu'il ait réussi à se payer un
crocodile suffit que le film était
particulièrement fâché qu'il a galéré de
ouf à faire ce film avec le budget
ridicule qu'il a réussi à obtenir de ses
emprunteurs d'ailleurs y sort d'où ce
crocodile au haut de la banque
ça alors mais qu'at-il bien pu vouloir
faire passer comme message par là bref
c'est donc dans cette atmosphère
d'apocalypse consommer que l'on va
trouver nos personnages dans un huit
clos qui va permettre à romero de
dérouler sa satire de l'âme humaine de
façon générale et de la hiérarchie
militaire en particulier
rien ne doit se passer ici sans qu'on
fasse un rapport aussi n'est que
possible et ensuite le premier futé qui
se permettra de désobéir passera en cour
martiale
il sera exécuté
parce que les personnages qu'il présente
dans ce film sont loin d'être des
tendres ce qui peut amener le spectateur
à se demander qui finalement le pire
entre l'humain et le zombi le zombie au
moins tu connais ses intentions manger
ont su en outre le point de vue d'un
personnage féminin entourée d'hommes
plus ou moins aimables ce qui accentue
encore le caractère anxiogène de la
situation le plus joli morceau de
bidoche de la guerre fait j'ai peur
d'exciter la collègue
et puis son petit ami est dans le coin
c'est vrai il n'a vraiment aucune chance
de maxit est acceptée sous l'angle
anthropologique bien son corps que ce
que tu as compris mais elle veut dire
que tu es un homme des cavernes eux
c'est tout devant toi de l'animal c'est
vrai que là la question se pose du coin
le pire entre l'humain et le zombi je
saurais pas dire au moins le zombie on a
le droit de le calmer à coups de pelle
quand il fait chier
le film pose en plus clairement la
question de la frontière entre l'humain
et le zombi puisqu'il met en scène un
scientifique qui trouve justement un
zombie ayant un semblant de conscience
et qu'il va tenter de l'éduquer c'est
intéressant parce qu'on assiste vraiment
là un phénomène de socialisation de
primaires comme si le zombie devait à
nouveau refaire tout le processus de
civilisation que nous avons déjà évoqué
mais les militaires ne voit pas
forcément ça du même oeil
c'est ça les progrès un c'est de laisser
ces saloperies gluante nous [__]
encore sur la gueule pays se dotent
début d'évolution
c'est le début aussi d'un comportement
social et d'être si mu et le
comportement social c'est ce qui nous
différencie des êtres inférieurs
c'est ce qui nous permettent de
communiquer elle est au devant des
choses de façon méthodique sens agressée
mutuellement comme des bêtes
mais bon va parler de comportement
social un militaire enfin ce film nous
pousse donc à réfléchir sur le thème de
l'humanité et à ce que les sociétés
humaines pourrait devenir une fois
poussés dans leurs retranchements et si
des comportements pourraient être
caractérisé d' inhumain des personnages
sont là pour rappeler que c'est
justement la nature humaine
qui peut ce problème il ne peut pas être
aussi humain c'est sûr pour ça que mes
frais et ce film propose d'ailleurs une
feinte intéressante puisque un des
personnages dégoûté par cette violence
choisit finalement de laisser les
zombies envahir le bunker comme pour le
purifier de tous ces humains vicié et
pour ce qui est du spectateur on ne peut
pas s'empêcher de ressentir une pointe
de satisfaction quand on voit le zombie
qui gagnaient peu à peu conscience
réussir à se servir d'une arme pour
éliminer le personnage qu'on déteste le
temps ah bah oui après c'est un peu sale
quand même hein ça reste des zombies et
cette satisfaction coupable que le
spectateur peut ressentir devant le
démembrement des personnages qu'il a
autant détesté est une nouvelle façon
pour romero de dénoncer nos travers les
moins reluisants
si c'est de façon indirecte dans le
rapport que je viens de décrire avec le
spectateur il représente lui-même à
l'écran des personnages qui ont l'air de
kiffer à fond la situation et de
profiter que les zombies ne soient plus
des êtres humains pour laisser éclater
leur violence on retrouve cela dans le
deuxième film quand des bikers libère le
centre commercial avec une joie non
contenue mais aussi dans le remake de
2004 quand les personnages passent le
temps en organisant une petite séance de
shooting sur zombie avec le voisin d'en
face
je le deviens soutien ouais attendent
tout au rang de fait dans cet extrait
comme dans la plupart des films de
zombies où on trouve des humains qui
shoote allègrement sur des zombies avec
plaisir les humains passent de proies
prédateurs et cela peut se faire par un
procédé cognitif de déshumanisation de
l'autre
je m'explique pour l'instant on ne sait
pas si les zombies sont des personnes
non c'est vrai que selon nos critères à
nous les zombies ne peuvent pas être
considérés comme des personnes parce que
ben ils ressemblent à des humains mais
il se comporte pas comme des humains ils
ont pas tous nos caractères sociaux tous
nos codes sociaux ils se contentent de
manger des cerveaux et c'est parce qu'on
considère être des humains
du coup puisque ce ne sont plus des
êtres humains on peut les défoncer sans
vergogne c'est la raison pour laquelle
un enfant pourra trucider ses parents ou
inversement puisque ils ont été
déshumanisé par le processus de
transformation en zombies et il se
trouve qu'on peut trouver un écho à ce
processus cognitif de déshumanisation de
l'autre dans les heures les plus sombres
de l'humanité
je parle par exemple de l'esclavagisme
où les esclaves n'étaient pas considérés
comme des êtres humains et du coup on
pouvait les tuer sans que ce soit
moralement condamnable et je vous
rappelle que le zoo
à l'origine c'est un mythe vaudou qui
est très liée à l' esclavage justement
mais on peut aussi trouver des exemples
dans les génocides comme la shoah
évidemment ou là le fait de penser que
les juifs ne sont pas des êtres humains
donne l'autorisation de les tuer sans
aucun problème mais voilà que je viens
d'atteindre un point godwin
ouch ça veut dire que la vidéo touche à
sa fin profitons-en pour conclure cette
excursion avait pour but de voir ce que
représente le zombie à part une masse de
chair dégradé dégoulinante est
dégueulasse si le mot zombies tire son
origine d'une pratique haïtienne la
façon dont nous l'utilisons aujourd'hui
est directement issu du cinéma américain
et plus spécifiquement du cinéma de
george romero qui a durablement marqué
le cinéma avec la quadrilogie des morts
vivants
ce qui est particulier intéressant dans
la figure du zombie c'est donc déjà
qu'elle extrêmement récente et en plus
ce qu'elle est réellement américaine
aussi bien dans son origine que dans les
messages qu'elle transporte parce que le
cinéma américain s'est déjà emparée de
nombreux folklore qui lui préexistaient
je veux dire tous les disney halloween
dracula même la révolution française
tout ça est passé à la moulinette du
cinéma américain mais on peut dire que
le zombie moderne c'est vraiment sa
création son bébé il est né dans
l'amérique des années 60 parce qu'il se
construit dès le départ comme une
critique de la société américaine
si les films de romero ont mis du temps
à être reconnue notamment en france où
ils ont longtemps été considérés comme
des films gore écervelée sans intérêt on
reconnaît petit à petit leurs intérêts
et maintenant tout le monde s'accorde
pour mettre en avant la dimension
critique et politique de son travail
si son premier film s'inscrit dans une
vague de contestation contre culturel il
est avant tout le reflet de son époque
et il est souvent considéré comme le
premier des midnight movies le travail
de romero gagne néanmoins en ampleur et
en finesse de film en film
au fur et à mesure qu'il fait avant
c'est l'apocalypse et qu'il étudie plus
profondément la figure du zombie il a
créé de fait entre le premier et le
troisième film on constate que le zombie
est tout d'abord considéré comme un
monstre étrange un autre radicalement
différent puis on apprend dans le
deuxième film qu'il leur reste
finalement des fragments de leur
humanité passé ce qui peut laisser
penser que les zombies sont une
évolution naturelle de notre société et
la frontière entre le bien et le
elle est encore plus poreuse dans le
troisième film rencontre un zombie qui
se forge peu à peu une conscience de
lui-même et où les personnages humains
semble finalement bien plus horrible que
les zombies qui combattent ce qui
entérine ainsi une critique radicale de
l'humanité apportant ainsi une
conclusion magnifique à son travail
alors juste une petite chose tu es au
courant qu'il ya des films de zombies
qui sont sortis après 1985 à eux
on en reparle au prochain épisode voilà
la vidéo est terminée j'espère qu'elle
vous a plu personnellement cela m'a pris
beaucoup beaucoup de temps pour tout
vous dire j'ai commencé à écrire cet
épisode d'au mois d'octobre 2016 donc ça
commence à faire plus d'un an et demi
que je travaille sur cet épisode qui a
été très long à mettre en place très
long à trouver les extraits très long à
tourner et surtout j'ai assez peu de
temps pour le faire est assez peu
d'occasions donc voilà c'est comme ça
tout tout tout prendre du temps donc
j'espère que ça vous a plu et puis
surtout il n'est pas fini comme vous
avez pu vous en doutez vous ne vous
j'avais vu que la première partie est du
coup la deuxième partie va est un jeu je
ne pas vous faire de promesse pour le
moment alors il ya toute une partie de
la deuxième vidéo qui est déjà tourné un
grosse partie mais il me reste encore
quand même quelques quelques petits
trucs à faire et vu mon emploi du temps
actuel je ne peux pas vous promettre de
date de sortie
en tout cas d'un j'espère que ça vous a
plu vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux
sur la chaîne quand bien même je ne suis
pas très actif j'ai maintenant une page
facebook que je vous invite à rejoindre
si ça vous intéresse je fais pas
beaucoup de postes mais je vais essayer
d'apprendre le plus actif et puis on
pourrait être plein de gens gentils et
puis changer
n'hésitez pas à échanger dans les
commentaires tout ça et puis moi je vous
dis à la prochaine et [__]
[Musique]